so how do you validate idea how do you
not waste a lot of time building
something that people don't need well I
think that the thing you need to do is
just build something and I realize that
sounds a little backwards to the way you
ask the question but you know you can
talk to as many people as you want in
life and you'll get some good answers
and some bad answers you know unless you
know how to ask the questions properly
you'll get a lot of bad answers but
really the best way to get people's
feedback is to build something and it
might not be the right thing but as long
as it has sort of you know the minimal
quanta of usable you know functionality
it gives people something to interact
with and then you start learning how
they use it what they really want and
you can go from there so if I'm an
early-stage startup and I want to do
user research what do i what do I do
I just build it and release it to the
market essentially yeah it really is you
know build something put it out there
see what happens know the way I would
modify that just a little and this is
why it's useful to be your own customer
is that if you're your own customer and
if you're building this thing for
yourself as you start developing it you
can actually figure out what you need
and what you don't need before you
release it and see what other people
need if you're building something for
someone you don't understand and it's
not you the first piece of feedback
you'll get is when you toss it out into
the world and getting people to engage
with something is hard enough getting
something getting people to engage with
something they don't actually want or
need at all is basically impossible so
if you build something that you need and
want you can get it to the point where
it solves your problem then you release
it and other people will be able to give
you feedback and really interact with it
and then you'll just get better faster
you make your iterations faster and how
do you make sure that you get the right
feedback from the right people how do
you make sure that's not like showing it
to your mother and she's saying hey
that's a great idea
yeah well mothers will usually tell you
your idea is very nice unless they
actually want you to go back to law
school which is what my mom keeps
justing although she suggested I go get
an MBA the other day I don't know why
you have to pick right you have to be
smart about it and and seek out the
people who you think will find what
you're doing is useful now some of that
is actually picking people by hand
looking at your network and saying hey
this person is the right demo the right
user type for what I'm building looks
like me or doesn't look like me but I
think I can solve their problem anyway
let me start with them the other way is
try to find some sort of distribution
early and there's a bunch of different
ways to do that if you're building a
product hacker news is an amazing place
to go because that's where a lot of
people who are interested in technology
congregate they go there they see what's
up they look at interesting articles we
have something called sho HN where
people just put up new products and
they'll get a lot of feedback a lot of
customers potential customers coming to
them you can use product hunt for the
same thing you know there's a bunch of
other things like that that you can use
but really it's about being real endless
there's a great story that Ben from
Pinterest tells you know the founder of
Pinterest and when he was starting
Pinterest didn't think and who would
want to use it and so he literally went
to coffee shops and showed the
prototypes of Pinterest to moms that he
saw at coffee shops he said these are
probably gonna be my demo let me see
what they think and he had them and each
note at coffee shops and it's that level
of Drive of just finding people who want
to use what you're building that's
critical in getting some sort of
engagement